MATTHEW GAUNT: Hi, everyone.
And thank you for joining me
for "Mobile Web Thursdays."
Sorry for the slight technical
issues with the
port casting live.
We had some minor issues
just as we
were about to go through.
We were actually really
organized as well, which is
kind of a shame.
My name is Matthew Gaunt.
I am a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And what this session is going
to be about is just the
approach that I take when I'm
developing a mobile site,
whether that be responsive
or specific to mobile.
Kind of up to you.
But I think a lot of the things
that I do, I kind of
don't want to get certain things
where I have to start
writing scripts and forcing
things to happen and regularly
start running tools.
So things like CSS minification,
HTML5
minification, all of these
little simple things that
should really just
be done for me.
And I essentially have a
setup that does that.
So what I'm going to introduce
you to is a tool called
Yeoman, which, if you're
not familiar with, it's
essentially a way of scaffolding
a project.
It kind of gives you a good
set of defaults for when
you're starting your
new project.
I'm now going to be talking
about some of the tools that
it gives you specific, so things
like autoprefixing, so
you no longer have to write
vendor prefixes.
We're also going to be looking
at live reloading how that can
help you with development
especially how that starts
applying to mobile devices as
well as simulators, talk about
some of the cross-device
approaches that you can take
and then also some of things
that are mobile-specific
things like network
conditioning.
So how do you get an impression
of what your mobile
users are experiencing on their
actual mobile devices
when they're out and about on
a 2G or 3G connection versus
what you're seeing on your
development machine where
ultimately everything
is local.
So the speed should be
surprisingly fast, and it
doesn't really cater for
real-world scenario.
So what I'm going to do first
off is create just a simple
Yeoman project.
So if I get Paul to shift
me over to my machine.
Yeah, there we go.
So what I'm going to do is
create a new directory for
this project GGL Workplay.
So if I go in there, now to
create a new project, all I
have to do is type yo web app.
So this is just kicking of
Yeoman and saying, create me a
new web app project.
So the website for this
is yeoman.io.
To get it installed is really
nice and simple.
So if I start yo webapp,
we get this
beautiful little gentleman.
And what it will do is it will
give me some preset defaults,
the HTML5 Boilerplate, jQuery,
and Modernizr.
But then it's also going to
run through a couple of
questions of certain things
I may or may not want.
So in this case, let's Twitter
Bootstrap for SaaS, which I'm
not too fussed about.
RequireJS, I always like
that for my JavaScript.
And this is a new one that's
only just come in.
And it's a little
bit half baked.
There's still a couple of fixes
the Yeoman team are
putting in.
But I'm really excited
about it.
So I'm going to be showing
you a little bit of
what that can do.
Now, what this goes and does,
is it starts setting up a
number of those requirements,
those dependencies.
So things like jQuery will go
and download the latest
version, same as Modernizr.
So what I'm going to do is just
show you what the file
structure is like.
And while I'm doing that, I'm
going to install some of the
dependencies the MPM needs.
So while that's going and doing
its thing, if I could
get this to zoom in, that
would be great.
Yeah.
There we go.
Sorry about that.
So this is the project that I
have created with Yeoman.
And basically, within this file
structure, you'll notice
you've got a set of files as
well as a set of directories.
So the app directory is
essentially where all your
source code is going to
go, all your CSS,
JavaScript, and HTML.
We then have bower.json.
Now, if you're not familiar with
Bower, what this is is
essentially a set of front-end
libraries.
And Bower is a tool that you
can use to just get those
dependencies and store them,
so things like jQuery.
And then it will also give
you a quick way of
updating them as well.
Grunt is a new tool which
you can kind of
think of as a helper.
So if you said you wanted to do
a certain task, you could
say, Grunt, perform
this task for me.
So an example would be
CSS modification.
You could have a specific
task for that.
But the nice thing with Grunt
is you can actually put
multiple tasks together
into one thing.
Node modules, this is what we're
downloading from MPM.
Package.json is the actual list
of dependencies that we
have, and then test where we
actually have a set of unit
tests and frameworks.
So if we go into app, which--
oh, OK.
Sorry.
My machine went a bit slow.
And again.
There we go.
So we got a set of defaults that
you'll be familiar with,
things like fav.ico, 404.html,
index.html, most of the text,
scripts and styles, and then
Bower components is things
like jQuery, Modernizr,
or RequireJS.
So if we actually looked at what
index.html consists of,
its given us some default
styling and text.
The idea with this is
that you're going
to delete it anyway.
But if I connect with Sublime,
this is where you'll start to
see where HTML5 Boilerplate
is come in.
So we've already got things like
a view port device with.
You'll notice we start adding in
default styles, and I'll go
over some of the nice things
that Grunt is giving you with
that, Modernizr, and then also
we've got a lot of things
around the Chrome frame Google
Analytics as well as RequireJS
already plummed in.
So the main reason I like using
Yeoman by default, is
that if I wanted to now view
this website and have a server
running with all the JavaScript
et cetera, all I
have to do is just type
grunt server.
I what this goes and does, is
it prepares all of my SaaS,
all of my JavaScript, et cetera,
and compiles it down
into the page, so then I've
already got a server ready on
my machine.
I don't need to go and set up
MAMP or anything like that.
It just runs a small Python
server on my machine.
And the way this is working, is
essentially, when you type
in grunt server, you're actually
sitting there and
saying, Grunt, I want you to
run your task name sever,
which if we go and look down
at the very bottom in the
grunt.js file, it's actually
just running this task here.
And this is really powerful in
the sense that you can start
getting LiveReload plummed
in for you.
You don't need to add
it in yourself.
So I'm just going to briefly
go through what Grunt is
actually doing.
So up at the top, we have
this LiveReload
port as well as snippet.
And all this is doing is
when you run a server--
there we go.
If I just zoom in, it might
be a bit easier to see.
So essentially, all this is you
this is doing is saying,
what port would you like the
LiveReload server to run on?
And then it prepares
a snippet.
So whenever you run Grunt
server, it will actually
insert the LiveReload code
for you only when
you're in Grunt server.
So if you want to distribute
this, you
could run Grunt Build.
It produces distribution-ready
version for you, and it won't
include the library
load code for you.
We then have a set of common
defaults, so here, you'll have
app in distribution.
So app is actually directory
where we're going to have all
of our development files, and
dist is going to be where
we're going to create the
distribution-ready version.
Watch is essentially the thing
that's going to be listening
for certain files when
they change.
When they change, LiveReload
knows to update for it.
So we've got things like SaaS,
Compass, Coffee files, things
along those lines.
Connect is where we actually
set up the initial server.
By default, you have local
hosters, any accessible on
this machine.
If you want to make it
accessible to all the mobile
devices on your network, which
we're going to want, we need
to change that to 0 dot 0000.
And then we've got a number
of different things.
So we've got test and
distribution, which again, the
Grunt build is going
to deal with.
Clean will actually make sure
that whenever you do another
distribution build, you're
removing all the out files,
Jshint will actually get fired
off whenever you try and
produce a build as well.
So during a development, you
can sit there, write the
JavaScript, and it will
produce it nicely.
And then at the end, when you
try to produce final build, it
will actually get jshinted.
So essentially, any wrong things
that you're doing,
things you should be improving
on, you're going to
be told about it.
Then we've obviously got things
to deal with Compass,
SaaS, autoprefixer, which I'm
going to show you a demo of in
a minute, proj S.
A whole chain of
things you can see here.
So the best way that I can show
you all of this, is if I
go and produce a new SaaS file,
so I'm going to name
this main.saas.
And what I want to do
as well is copy over
the existing stuff.
So where we've already got the
existing styles, I don't want
them anymore.
So what I'm going to do is just
move those over to trash.
So what this is now doing is,
I've refreshed it so it should
start pulling in the
new file already.
If it's not, why not?
Yeah, that should be there.
There we go.
So what I've done is just moved
everything to a SESS
file, so we know that Compass
is going to pull this.
And one the nice things with
the autoprefixer that I was
talking about is if I just type
in display flex, normally
you'd have to type in the WebKit
equivalent, the Mozilla
version, et cetera.
And the idea with the
autoprefixer is it knows that
this is what you're
trying to do.
So if I now go to this page,
what it should do is start
applying these styles in line.
So if I go to the inspect
element for this page where
I've applied display flex, what
you should be able to see
is where we've originally just
typed in display flex, the
autoprefixer is already
added in WebKit box,
WebKit flex, MS Flexbox.
And the moment it's not doing
Mozilla prefixes, but I think
this is a bug that the Yeoman
teams are already working on.
So I'm actually going to change
that to .container.
So that should actually
produce something
slightly more sane.
There we go.
No, it hasn't.
Why it won't?
OK.
It's not important anyway.
But the idea with this is
essentially that you're
already getting to
a point where it
should simplify things.
And obviously, if it comes to a
point where this isn't quite
working for you because there's
not enough or you need
the Mozilla things now, you
can literally start using
Compass in this as well.
So do the
@includeDisplayFlexbox, and
that will start coming into
play for you as well.
So the next thing I want to talk
about is, even if we've
got this build process where
we're adding in additional
prefixes, one of the key things
is this minification.
You want to reduce the size of
your CSS and JavaScript.
So if I write Grunt build, what
this is actually going to
do is start doing all of the
hard and heavy lifting for me
so that I don't need to do it.
So what it's doing is running
through Uglify, CSSmin,
HTMLmin, and once it's finished,
you can go back to
your main directory.
And you'll notice we've now
got this dist build.
Now what this is, is it's
minified version of
everything.
So if I open this up
in Chrome, this is
exactly the same page.
But if I inspect some
of the CSS, where
can I find some CSS?
Yeah, there.
I'm going to--
you know what?
Let's open it in Sublime mode.
It might be easier,
wouldn't it?
So first, you already notice
that it's already added like
an ID to this file where it's
been compiled for you, and
Grunt will actually inject that
into the web page, so you
don't need to worry about
maintaining that.
But you can see that it's
already started
adjusting the CSS.
The only thing you have to be
aware of is if you start using
break points in multiple files,
it will actually bring
all the files into one.
So you do sometimes need to name
the files in numerical
order is the best way that
I've found so you have
naught, one, two.
The main reason of that is the
position of your media queries
is important as to which one
gets affected, which one's the
actual one that applies to start
with, the last one on
the style sheet.
So you need to make sure
that they're added
in the correct order.
So all of this is good and well,
but at the same time, we
want to start using this
on a mobile device.
So we've got best practices in
place where we're reducing the
file sizes, which is great for
mobile, but how do we now
start playing with this?
So I've got a device set up
with one of the cameras I
think Paul is going to quickly
shift over to.
So at the moment, we've got that
mobile device and then on
my machine, we want the two
to start talking together.
So if I go to my localhost
9000, at the
moment, that does nothing.
And it would be great if we
can join the two together.
So on my desktop machine, we've
actually got this new
plug-in which has been written
between Pavel and Paul Irish.
And what this does is it gives
you the ability to start
looking at what ADB is seeing.
Now, ADB is the Android
Debug Bridge.
So if you click on this, you'll
notice we've got start
ADB and then View Devices.
So if I kick this off, what it
should start doing is fire up
the ADB, the debug server
essentially,
for the Android devices.
And if I unplug my device back
in, you'll notice that it's
now changed to number 1.
So this is saying there's one
device connected to this
machine that it's aware of.
So if I now click on View
Devices, it will open up
Chrome Inspect, which is where
we'll now start seeing this
Galaxy Nexus, which is the
device I have here.
And one of them is localhost
9000, which we had open.
So if I click on Inspect, what
this is doing is opening up
the dev tools for this device,
so the current
beater running on here.
And if I click on the Options,
I'm going to have to zoom out
a little bit.
There we go.
So on the Experiments tab, for
the dev tools, I've got Enable
reverse port forwarding, which
then brings up Port
Forwarding.
And now I've entered in just
a mapping for 9000 to 9000.
So what that's doing is saying,
on my local machine, I
have port 9000.
Map it to the devices
port 9000.
So when I now hit Refresh on
my device, we'll get this.
So now I can actually start
playing around with the
elements right from dev tools
like you normally
would on the desktop.
So what can I do?
Allo, GDL.
You guys rock.
So already, you're starting to
be able to play around with
the dev tools that you're used
to on your mobile device.
The one problem with this is
obviously it works on Chrome
for Android, but it's
not necessarily a
cross-browser solution.
This is particularly useful when
you want to start looking
at performance time lines and
other things that are specific
to the dev tools in Chrome.
But if you want to start testing
across a range of
devices, at that point, you need
to start looking at how
you're going to essentially
connect your local machine to
any device.
So I've got an iPhone with me.
And the best way to do it
essentially at the moment
seems to be to have all the
devices connected on the same
network and make the server on
your local machine available
to these other devices.
And there are a couple of
tools out there that add
additional features
to this, so you've
got like Adobe Inspect.
You got Remote Preview, which
is an open source tool.
The one thing they tend not to
offer though is the ability to
just say, here's a URL launch
across devices.
So there is still a little
bit of leg work
that you need to do.
But because we've done Grunt
server and we've changed the
host name to naught, naught,
naught, naught, what I can do
is just connect to the IP
address of my machine when I
get this iPhone working.
It will work, or maybe it won't
The server is running on
my machine.
OK, maybe it won't work.
We always have slight issue in
the Google studio in the sense
that we've got multiple
networks going off at
different times.
But anyway, one of the main
disadvantages of doing this at
the very moment is, you have
to also open up a port for
live reloading on your Android
device as well as your
development console.
So often, it's a good option
to sit there and go for
naught, naught, naught on the
same network, because at that
point when you're pointing to
this specific machine, what
Grunt will also take care of
is it will inject the IP
address of your machine for the
LiveReload file as well.
So if I click at the demo work
in the iPhone, what would
happen is when I start editing
my main SaaS file, so I could
actually say, I can show you
a demo of it in the browser
where normally I'd be off to
sit there and say, hey, I
don't like this color.
I'm going to change
it to black.
No, it helps if I was
in the right file.
So if I change that to naught,
naught, naught, what this will
then do is notice a change
in the Grunt file.
Stop breaking.
It will notice a change in the
SaaS file and then it should
actually kick off a LiveReload
on the server, which will then
update all the browser
channels.
Why it's not, I'm
not quite sure.
Oh, I remember.
So I apologize.
I'm on a cutting-edge
version of Yeoman.
So occasionally, I have
the brunt of issues.
What I did there was there was
a current issue with noSpawn
equals true, which actually
results in some weird quirks
which team has already fixed,
but I haven't quite pulled the
fixed yet myself.
So the idea here is again, like
I said-- there we go.
When I changed the SaaS file,
it should already
update the web page.
And the problem here is this
actually requires a certain
port that I can't get going
on this device.
So like I said, use the network
IP address for the
machine and then everything
should start playing nicely.
So let's say all of this
was good and well.
We go through all
this process.
We've got minified CSS
and JavaScript.
We've tested it on a range
of devices, and we're
ready to launch it.
One of the big things that
you're never going to really
experience in your device is the
network speed of a mobile
device while you're developing
locally especially when you're
on the various networks.
Now, one of the ways you can do
this is there a couple of
proxy tools out there that will
actually enable you to
restrict the speed that you
have available onto these
devices essentially, any
connections going in and out
of your laptop.
So one of the examples here is
network link conditioner.
So if I--
nope.
And essentially, what this will
do when I enable it, I'm
not going to use the worst
connection network because I
tried that once.
And let's use a preset
that I did.
And I actually network
connection
to log into my machine.
So that was a bit weird.
Anyway, so essentially if I go
to my own website here because
I know it's particularly
a bad example for this
unfortunately, I get quite fast
reload times, and that's
because I'm on a good, solid
ethernet connection.
Whereas if I hit the Network
Link Conditioner, then if I
hit Refresh, you'll notice
that the network speed is
going to be much, much slower.
Now I'm also noticing that I'm
streaming this to the box
through the network.
So I'm wondering whether that's
going to effect it.
But anyway you notice that the
speed time actually started
slowing down.
I've actually done a little bit
of work to improve this.
I swapped out some of the PNGs
for JPEGs and compressed them
a little bit.
But I've got an example where
before it had done any of
that, I'd actually recorded
the two side
by side in the emulator.
So if you look at my web page,
my desktop, yeah, there we go.
So if I just kick this off, what
this is going to do is
load the page roughly about
the same time, but you'll
notice that the speed
differences is quite hefty.
And not only is it kind of a
good indication of what your
website is going to be like for
these users, but often you
can almost find situations where
if the fonts and the
text actually loaded before any
of the background images,
sometimes you can actually get
way with just setting your
background color.
So that way if you've got a
light font and you've actually
just been putting it on a white
page, if you just set a
background color, that text
suddenly becomes readable and
is quite usable.
I use Link Conditioner iOS 6.
There is also [INAUDIBLE],
which I think is a cross
platform proxy tool as well.
So the main reason why I
encourage people to look at
Yeoman as well as Grunt is the
sense that what we're doing is
looking at how people actually
develop in mobile devices,
especially what kind of tools
they're bringing in and
whether there are certain
things we can
automate for them.
So one of things that I've
beginning to start trying to
do is look at WebP.
So you should only ever have to
produce PNG files or JPEGS,
and then there should be a
way of just automatically
compressing them to WebP.
There's also kind of a lot of
discussion between the group
of us of how we could actually
like produce source sets and
other things like that.
And plus it's kind of getting
to that point where if there
are certain things that you want
to do like you want to
launch a browser stack instance
with localhost
tunneled through, there are
Grunt tasks for browser stack
as well the source labs and
a lot of the other tools.
So at that point, you can almost
imagine a scenario
where instead of going Grunt
server, you could take Grunt
browser stack and set up a task
on your machine, and it
will actually just start setting
that up for you.
And even if there are particular
build steps for
your specific project, you
can create those tasks.
So I'm sorry I couldn't show
you the iPhone network
connection along with
the live reloading.
There are a lot of things
going on with the Yeoman
project like I know the
team are working
really, really hard.
A lot of the changes are going
to come in quite soon are
actually going to improve this
flow even better than what it
already is.
So I definitely encourage
you to go check out
if you haven't already.
Beyond that, I'd love to know
what your process is, what
sort of things you're doing.
And Germany, if you start giving
this a go, give us as
much feedback as you can,
because I'd love to know where
the pain points are for you.
Other than that, thank
you for watching.
I hope it's been useful.